et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
pierre villa président du syndicat de
l'exploitation cinématographique du
centre-sud bonsoir jean pierre villa
merci d'être avec nous à vos côtés ben
jama ma professeure d'histoire porte
parole cgt 94 bonsoir benjamin amar
merci également à vous aide à trouver
d'actionnaires t france ce soir on
commence par ces manifestations du
secteur de la culture on a vu ces images
beaucoup m'ont dans les rues de paris
aujourd'hui notamment en province
également théâtre cinéma devrait rugby
devait rouvrir aujourd'hui enfin
finalement ça n'a pas lieu une
mobilisation la hauteur de votre colère
jean pierre villa oui je crois que le
monde de la culture globalement est tout
à fait dans une situation complètement
incompréhensible comme l'a dit un
désintérêt interview précédent nous
avons eu vingt cinq millions de
spectateurs pendant l'été lorsque les
cinémas étaient rouverts il n'y a pas eu
un seul le ster n'y a pas eu un seul cas
de continue de contamination à
l'intérieur des cinémas donc l'acide la
décision qui a été prise vous paraît
totalement incompréhensible elle vous
paraît aussi tu as fait injuste dans la
mesure où nous ne nous appliquons des
aussi bien dans les théâtres de grade
que dans les cinémas des protocoles
sanitaires extrêmement sérieux
extrêmement précis et nous les
respectons totalement et lilian à notre
sens pas plus de dangers à venir au
cinéma qu'à fréquenter un grand magasin
où la rue montorgueil qu'on ne s'était
montré dans les images précédentes on va
faire évidemment benjamin en a marre sur
ce thème de la culture également mais
bon je voudrais vous faire avoir sa
tâche tag qui a vu le jour sur les
réseaux sociaux culture en danger pas
mal de politiques s'en sont emparés pour
faire passer des messages
regardez par exemple celui de constance
le grip la députée les républicains
n'est hauts-de-seine
j'exprime toute ma solidarité et mon
soutien au monde de la culture dont je
partage la déception et la colère
monsieur le prix
10dans emmanuel macron entendez
l'amertume des professionnels de la
culture et notre tristesse à tous
benjamin a marre vous on nous a souvent
eu pour militer pour la fermeture des
écoles vous jugiez sa nécessaire
aujourd'hui quelle est votre réaction
quand vous voyez que finalement les
cinémas les théâtres restent fermés
c'est une bonne chose là aussi où vous
le critiquez alors d'abord souvenons
nous a effectivement on a participé à
des débats ensemble ce que vous évoquez
c'était effectivement au mois de mai
deux mois du mois de juin où
effectivement nous assumions et nous
assumons toujours d'avoir exigé à ce
moment là la fermeture des écoles mais
savait lénine disait analyse concrète de
la situation concrète
aujourd'hui c'est le deuxième
confinement fatalement les la situation
n'est pas la même et on n'a pas les
mêmes analyses qu'on avait au mois de
mai ou deux mois de juin aujourd'hui en
décembre surtout on essaie d'avoir un
peu de cohérence moi j'écoutais ce que
disait l'interlocuteur précédent et je
rejoins tout à fait ce qu'il dit jean
castex a dit tout à l'heure que une
certes il ya une exception culturelle
mais ça n'est pas une exception
une exception sanitaires mais en fait ce
que fait le gouvernement c'est une
exception culturelle à l'envers on peut
dire les choses d'une manière assez
simple
moi je parlais avec un camarade de la
cgt culture tout à l'heure il me disait
on peut aller écouter un morceau de bach
dans une église mais on ne peut pas
aller écouter un morceau de mac dans une
salle de concert
c'est moi je prends les transports en
commun tous les jours alors où prendre
métro sans problème dans les heures de
pointe on est agglutinée les uns contre
les autres mais par contre dans les
lieux de culture
visiblement la même situation et même
d'ailleurs avec le protocole sanitaire
que l'interlocuteur précédent évoqué là
c'est impossible on a un monde de la
culture qui est exemple on a un
gouvernement qui visiblement considèrent
que l'économie financière ça doit
tourner à plein mais que le la vie
culturelle c'est autre chose en même
temps quand on entend ce qu'a dit
marlène schiappa hier par exemple sur le
pcf sur le parti communiste français qui
en 1905 ne tenait pas le même discours
alors qu'en 1900 simple parti communiste
français n'existait pas on comprend
visiblement que pour les maquereaux nist
la culture générale ça soit pas
essentiel jean pierre villa c'est vrai
qu'on a du mal
à comprendre parce qu'on a entendu des
discours des manuels macron consacré
d'ailleurs exclusivement à la culture et
là on nous parle de mépris on a entendu
effectivement cet interlocuteur dans
notre reportage des syndicats qui
s'estime par entendu pas de concertation
la politique du yo yo c'est de ça
finalement que vient la colère
aujourd'hui du monde de la culture plus
que pour la fermeture en elle-même
finalement parce que je crois que c'est
l'expression les décisions
gouvernementales exprime un choix très
précis que vous collègue françois aymé
président de l'association française des
cinémas réussi résume de la façon
suivante oui aux consommateurs non aux
spectateurs c'est vraiment un choix qui
fait de privilégier la consommation par
rapport la culture je pense que le
gouvernement prend ses responsabilités
et que voilà le je pense que le monde de
la culture sera en temps voulu me rendre
la monnaie de la pièce la voix lasse et
nous avons le sentiment d'une totale
injustice le sentiment de ne pas la
justice qui a en même temps des
conséquences dramatiques
rendons nous compte que lorsque nous
reprendrons éventuellement à la fin du
mois de janvier nous aurons passé 200
jours de fermeture
quelle est l'entreprise puisque ou un
théâtre comme au cinéma sont aussi des
lieux d'expression culturelle mais aussi
les entreprises
comment dans ces conditions même avec
des aides qui peuvent exister
comment dans ces conditions du don qui
n'a risque diminué à fonctionner avec
200 jours de fermeture sur 360
aujourd'hui dans des laines de 35
millions d'euros
elle ne compte pas ne pèse pas où elle
ne suffit pas série 10 35 millions
d'euros pour la culture c'est totalement
ridicule
le premier ministre au moment où il a
fait sa déclaration d'amour au cinéma
lorsqu'il est venu au festival
elle a mis en avant une enveloppe de 160
millions qui devaient arriver au sein de
ce qui est peut-être arrivé au cndd et
les cinémas là dessus anne ont récupéré
environ 30 millions que telle est la
remarque en les l'incroyable écart qu'il
ya entre les 160 millions théorique qui
devaient être versées ou sans franchir
du sien et les 35 millions tonnes
aujourd'hui sont destinés à l'ensemble
de la culture
je pense que on se montre le loue
actuellement en tout cas à quelques
jours des fêtes de fin d'année un le
gouvernement semble très inquiet de voir
les contaminations exploser le conseil
scientifique recommande même à ceux qui
le peuvent de ne pas mettre leurs
enfants à l'école en fin de semaine pour
s'auto confiné je me propose d'écouter
jean castex que conseil scientifique dit
quelque chose je parle de très
raisonnable il dit d'abord si vous le
pouvez d'ailleurs c'est ce qui se
pratique dans certains pays étrangers
dont beaucoup au tout confiné vous huit
jours avant noël si vous pouvez ce n'est
pas possible vous habiller cette
recommandation bien entendu pour ta
chaque fois que cela est possible
surtout si on doit recevoir à noël des
personnes vulnérables
le conseil scientifique je veux dire
qu'on l'appuie a même dit si vous pouvez
ne pas amener vos enfants l'école jeudi
et vendredi c'est la période de huit
jours pour le fun alors benjamin arts
vous êtes professeur d'histoire j'ai
envie de vous poser la question comment
on s'organise en deux jours alors on met
des enfants mais pas les enfants comment
comment ça se passe et j'ai écouté un le
passage que vous venez de de transmettre
et j'ai failli tomber de ma chaise
honnêtement moi je considère qu'on fait
dans cette pandémie
elle révèle beaucoup de choses d'abord
elle révèle en réalité l'état
je dirais le la fragilité et la
vulnérabilité des services publics
finalement impactée depuis depuis un
certain nombre d'années par les
politiques libérales qui ont cassé des
moyens et en plus on a comme double
effet kiss cool l'incohérence de ce
gouvernement qui nous donne l'impression
sur tous les sujets en lien avec cette
pandémie de courir partout comme un
poulet sans tête
honnêtement j'ai mais y'a rien qui tient
quoi nous en tant qu'enseignant on a dû
se bagarrer se mobiliser
rentrée de la toussaint parce que en
fait le gouvernement nous faisait tout
va très bien on regardait les mêmes flux
regardait exactement le même protocole
on nous disait juste d'ouvrir les
fenêtres
voilà il a fallu qu'on se mobilise
pendant une dizaine de jours pour
obtenir enfin une un peu plus d'une
semaine pour obtenir enfin effectivement
de l'adaptation de la souplesse pour
travailler en demi groupe etc
c'est pas satisfaisant mais au moins
effectivement ça limitait la propagation
du virus et à l'époque on avait un
gouvernement qui traînaient des cas de
faire un ministère qui freinaient des
quatre fers et là ils nous disent à quoi
à quelques jours des vacances vous savez
quoi auto confirmez vous mais enfin je
veux dire honnêtement mais quelle
cohérence il ya là dedans je sais plus
quoi dire à mes élèves en face les
élèves eux mêmes ils sont dans une
situation et il ya beaucoup d'ironie et
de sarcasme voilà ben ça me dit que
voulez vous je pense que pour reprendre
un adjectif qui emmanuel macron aime
bien l'hôte le taux d'auto confinement
samedi matin parce que moi j'ai cours
samedi matin avec mes élèves
il va être pro quinio losc voit la mémé
jacquet ce qu'on a comme comcast la bête
parents d'élèves ben najah marque
justement quand il n'y laisse à me dire
quoi vous pensez que ça va être suivi
tous les badges je pense je me trompe
peut-être à vous parents on regarde non
mais il ya beaucoup d'évaluation en fin
d'année alors on se demande en tant que
parent finalement on est partagés on se
dit ben voilà on va pénaliser nos
enfants de ne pas les mettre et dans le
même temps on va peut-être pénalisé les
grands parents qu'on va avoir quelques
jours plus tard donc c'est vrai que ça
mais une responsabilité sur le dos des
parents qui est importante et est
compliquée peut-être à gérer alors vous
avez tout à fait raison de toutes les
façons il faut savoir que la patate
chaude
le ministère en réalité la balance au
lors du premier confinement c'était pour
les mères vous vous souvenez ou rejeter
la responsabilité sur les mers ensuite
monsieur blanc caire nous expliquer au
mois de novembre
confie d'allemands c'était localement
dans les établissements publics
notamment dans les lycées qu'on pouvait
voir comment est-ce qu'on aménage et les
choses
bon voilà et là maintenant effectivement
il ya beaucoup de choses qui repose sur
les familles mais dans le monde réel
dans le monde réel dans la vraie vie moi
je suis prof depuis 20 ans un samedi par
exemple un vendredi ou un samedi matin
de veille scolaire va de veille de
vacances scolaires la densité dans les
classes avaient pas optimale avec cette
annonce du du gouvernement il est
évident qu'on va se retrouver moi je
suis sûr que dans ma classe je vous
dirai si ma prédiction est mauvaise mais
je risque de me retrouver avec deux
pelés et trois tondus samedi matin en
place mais j'entendais monsieur castex
tout à leur dire évoqué comment ça se
passe dans d'autres dans d'autres pays
c'est marrant parce que le goût pour la
comparaison européenne il est à
géométrie variable sur votre antenne au
mois de mai quand comme mon syndicat
signalait qu'en italie par exemple on
avait décidé de reporter la rentrée
scolaire à septembre le gouvernement
pousser des cris d'orfraie et là
maintenant monsieur castex nous dit mais
là bas ailleurs ça se passe comme ça
faye a aucune cohérence je pense le
gouvernement ne sait plus où il habite
le problème c'est que nous derrière on
est impacté par ce gouvernement qui
ressemble encore une fois un poulet sans
tête
jean pierre villa le mot de la fin vous
et les veaux auto confiné
quelle est votre réaction par rapport à
ce conseil parce que c'est vrai c'est
pas une obligation de d'auto confinement
c'est vrai que ça mais les français dans
une situation qui peut peut-être
particulière et confuse
je pense que nous sommes toute la
profession est dans un état de choc
nous avons beaucoup investi pour offrir
aux spectateurs une des vacances de noël
une fin d'année qui soit un peu plus
optimiste que un peu plus festive que ce
qu'il y avait été ce cas était 2020 nous
le proposions en toute sécurité et
l'investissement qui a été fait a
brutalement été arrêté par par ce coup
d'arrêt extraordinairement fort la seule
le seul point positif c'est la certitude
que les spectateurs attendent la
réouverture du cinéma attend de la
réouverture de théâtre parce que la
vraie vie elle et pas devant l'internet
elle n'est pas sur les réseaux elle et
pas sur les plates formes la vraie vie
la vraie vie culturelle la vraie vie
sociale elle est dans les théâtres
elle est dans les cinémas elle est dans
le la relation humaine est aujourd'hui
j'espère qu'on n'est pas en train de
vous préparer une société tout le
numérique
n'oublions pas que les arbres se
découvre sur un plateau de théâtre les
arbres se découvre sur un écran en
partage entre l'ensemble des spectateurs
et ces choses là aujourd'hui sont
remises en cause et c'est extrêmement
compliqué extrêmement dur mais on garde
l'espoir d'un d'une possible renaissance
lorsque les conditions sanitaires seront
meilleures ou que l'on voudra bien
regarder la réalité dans le
fonctionnement de l'ensemble de ses pays
clés de ces cinémas les français seront
certainement au rendez vous les français
qui ont bien besoin
voilà de deux cultures pour leur
remonter le moral en ce moment merci à
tous les deux jean pierre villa merci
également à benjamin a marre